on peut le dire aujourd'hui
jean michel maire va faire le bachelor
jean michel maire va être le nouveau
bachelor mais non si c'est pas une vraie
l'élastique
sur ces huit brigode ces pauvres ah oui
mon tour et les pauvres
on espère qu'on va trouver des
prétendantes
revoir les séries quand j'ai dit que
c'était fort est ce que déjà je vous ai
menti à la puissance et puissant très
puissant
jean michel maire le bachelor est ce que
déjà jean michel maire en bachelor bonne
ou mauvaise idée
dites la vérité est vite nous chez vous
jean michel maire dans le bachelor est
ce que ce une bonne ou mauvaise idée
restait alors vous savez que maresca vos
places à jean-luc franchement non c'est
de bonnes idées
c'est ça accroche c'est vrai que ça on a
envie de voir ça plein les filles déjà
mais on a envie de voir ça nous allons
devoir faire du cash pour pouvoir faire
des débris finances va pleurer de rire
et bages en privé ce qui m'inquiète plus
c'est d'avoir mis mathieu la transaction
non mais on n'a pas encore dit la mairie
n'avait pas de lui savonner perial la
suisse à l'ue lui savait de jl oui je
vous dis oui
non je trouve ça triste triste pour lui
si triste pour ces pauvres jeunes femmes
à l'avenir avant quand même j'ai peur
qu'elles sont broyés de l'expérience
alors non j'aime il va bouffer fonds de
commerce et les tripoter un vrai
gentleman et sa bonne ou mauvaise idée
ah mais moi j'ai eu une excellente idée
ça me fait beaucoup rire j'aime pas
programme des tests le bois mais vous
savez quoi jean michel sera probablement
de tous les bâches l'heure le plus
sincère souvent les bâches l'heure le
font pour être connu lui il a pas besoin
il est déjà connu il a un peu de sous
donc je pense que lui à l'abri trouvé
vraiment voir ce coup là je deviendrai
que ça sera plus ça sera la plus
professionnelle est ouest
[Applaudissements]
mathieu franchement bonne idée au mot
réside non vraiment bonne idée parce
qu'en vrai quand on le connaît un petit
peu ça sera certainement le plus
gentleman c'est un garçon qui est très
étonnant mais c'est vrai que je suis
désolé tu le voyais une fille tient la
porte et tous un gain sont pas vraiment
des manières à la sienne il tient à port
pour quelque chose
ah les us et par la mer dont il est très
remonté très romantique et très
respectueux des femmes
on devrait donc je pense que ça va être
parfait alvar bonne idée jean michel
maire de gauche de ce week-end quoi oui
mais j'ai hâte de le voir dans ce rôle
je ne discuterai pas du programme jeunes
à regarder ça m'aide début à la fin par
seconde il va être formé avant plus
effet il va être drôle c'est ça qui va
choisir les filles quoi vous met bien en
ce moment pas papa merci mes meilleures
idées je trouve je pense que tout le
monde va a envie de regarder là comme ça
je pense qu'on a très envie que ça
arrive
et en plus il va enfin pouvoir sortir de
son rôle du gros lourdaud de biens non
non mais ça finit mal à l'amour à tout
ça si ce case
qu'est ce qu'il va devenir dans
l'émission en dessinant une aventure
avec sa nouvelle
j'adore fils maxime il va marquer
l'histoire du beh la manière mais le cas
si c'est assez improbable de votre part
de vous voir comme ça dans de nouveaux
habits j'attends de voir la série de la
rose et vous êtes dans un des formats
encore les puits puis sur la télévision
aux états unis qu'à plus de 18 saisons
où vous allez faire une saison hors du
commun
alors une question oui une envie celle
de jean-michel pourquoi avez-vous dit
oui j'ai dit oui parce que voilà parce
que je suis célibataire donc ça tombe
bien profitons-en qu'avec est ce que
c'est parce que aussi voilà c'est une
question de sous deux de nos meilleurs
je n'ai jamais regardé live qu'est-ce
que j'ai jamais rien fait de ma vie pour
l'argent pour moi j'aurais pété
journaliste voile à lorient avec des
docks fnpd jamais créé difficultés j'ai
jamais fait votre tirer profit de quoi
que ce soit dans les choses comme
proposé moi je suis je suis une sorte de
troubadours on voit la nôtre les jolies
femmes du bon vin et des amis qui on
rigole mois la vie et la vie est belle
pour moi car datant d'avant la bonne ou
mauvaise idée que c'est une très bonne
idée mais s'y met y aura un twist sur
les femmes qu'on lui présentait pas du
tout il ya pas de siège
hanoi a aucun pied là c'est un vrai
macho ya aucun piège match déjà qu'une
question puisque haut nos fins mais il a
quand même 76 ans est laurent quel âge
de maçonnerie dans ma loge il y aura de
tout non mais toutes les femmes qui sont
séduites et kirby devient las vegas deux
candidats devaient commencer à vous
inscrire on vous dira dès demain comment
faire en tout cas et on va voir je vous
dirais je vous demande en viager
voilà à quoi alors on va voir les plus
tôt ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit de lire
sur cette idée jean michel maire qui
fait le bachelor idées à 47% à 1 53
oui mais bon quand même choisi la salle
était vrai nom mais s'il faut vraiment
saluer et bien sûr vous allez vous
demander ce que le format est un peu
particulier à particulier
un mouvement demander tout ce que vient
faire match nul en mots là-dessus
bachand est ma chérie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]